solve this system and here we have three
equations with three unknowns and just
so you have a way to visualize this each
of these equations would actually be a
plane in three dimensions and so you're
actually trying to figure out where
three planes in three dimensions
intersect I won't go into the details
here I'll focus more on the mechanics
but you could imagine if I were to draw
three dimensional space over here now
all of a sudden we'll have an x y and
z-axes so you can imagine that maybe
this first plane and I'm not drawing it
the way it might actually look might
look something like that I'm just
drawing part of the plane and maybe this
plane over here it intersects right over
there and it comes popping out like this
and then it goes behind it like that
keeps going in every direction I'm just
drawing part of the plane and maybe this
plane over here maybe it does something
like this maybe it intersects over here
and over here and so it pops out like
that and then it goes below it like that
it goes like that I'm just doing this
for visualization purposes and so the
intersection of this plane the XY and z
coordinates that would satisfy all three
of these constraints the way I drew them
would be right over here so that's what
we're looking for in a lot of times
these three sister equation with three
unknown systems won't they will be
inconsistent you won't have a solution
here because it's very possible to have
three planes that all don't intersect in
one place a very simple example of that
is well one they could all be parallel
to each other or they could intersect
each other but maybe they intersect each
other in kind of a triangle so maybe one
plane looks like that then another plane
another plane maybe pops out like that
goes underneath and then maybe the third
plane cuts in it does something like
this where it goes into that plane and
keeps going out like that but it
intersects this plane over here so you
see this kind of forms a triangle and
they don't all intersect in one point so
in this situation you would have an
inconsistent system so with that out of
the way let's try to actually solve this
system and the trick here is to try to
eliminate one variable at a time from
all of the equations making sure that
you have
the information from all three equations
here so what we're going to do is we
could maybe it looks like the easiest to
eliminate since we have a positive Y to
negative Y and then another positive Y
it seems like we can eliminate the Y's
we can add these two equations and come
up with another equation that will only
be in terms of X and Z and then we could
use these two equations to come up with
another equation that will only be in
terms of X and Z but it'll have all of
the all of the X and z constraint
information embedded in it because it
has all we're using all three equations
so let's do that
so first let's add these two equations
right over here so we have X plus y
minus 3z is equal to negative 10 and X
minus y plus 2z is equal to 3 so over
here we if we want to eliminate Y we can
literally just add these two equations
so on the left hand side X plus X is 2x
y plus negative Y cancels out and then
negative 3z plus 2z that gives us just a
negative Z and then we have negative 10
plus 3 which is negative 7 so using
these two equations we got 2x minus Z is
equal to negative 7 just adding these
two equations now let's do these two
equations we can and we can reuse this
equation as long as we're using new
information here now we're using the
extra constraint of this bottom equation
so we have X minus y plus 2z is equal to
3 and we have 2x 2x plus y minus z is
equal to negative 6 if we want to
eliminate the Y's we can just add these
two equations so X plus 2x is 3x
negative y plus y cancels out 2 Z minus
Z well that is just Z and that is going
to be equal to 3 plus negative 6 is
negative 3 so if I add these two
equations I get 3x plus Z is equal to
negative 3 now I have a system of two
equations with two unknowns this is a
little bit more traditional of a problem
so let me write them over here so we
have 2x minus Z is equal to negative
seven and then we have three X plus Z is
equal to negative three and the way this
problem is set up it gets pretty simple
pretty fast because if we just add these
two equations disease cancel out
otherwise if it didn't happen so
naturally we would have to multiply one
of these equations or maybe both of them
by some scaling factor but we can just
add these two these two equations up on
the left-hand side
2x plus 3x is 5x negative Z plus Z
cancels out negative 7 plus negative 3
that is equal to negative 10 divide both
sides of this equation by 5 and we get X
is equal to negative 2 now we can
substitute back to find the other
variables we will use we can substitute
back into this equation to figure out
what Z must be equal to so we have 2
times X 2 times negative 2 minus Z is
equal to negative 7 or negative 4 minus
Z is equal to negative 7 we can add 4 to
both sides of this equation and then we
get negative Z is equal to negative 7
plus 4 is negative 3 multiply or divide
both sides by negative 1 and you get Z
is equal to 3 and now we can go and
substitute back into one of these
original equations so we have X we know
X is negative 2 so we have negative 2
plus y minus 3 times Z well we know Z is
3 minus 3 times 3 should be equal to
negative 10 and now we just solve for y
so we get negative 2 plus y minus 9 is
equal to negative 10 and so negative 2
minus 9 that's negative 11 so we have Y
minus 11 is equal to negative 10 and
then we have so we can add 11 to both
sides of this equation and we get Y is
equal to negative 10 plus 11 is 1 so
we're done we got X is equal to negative
2 Z is equal to 3 and Y is equal to 1
and now we can actually go back and
check it verify that this XY and Z works
all three constraints that this this
three dimensional coordinate lies on all
three planes so let's try it out we got
X is negative 2 Z is 3 y is 1 so if we
substitute it let me do it into each of
them so in this first equation that
means that negative negative 2 plus 1
remember Y was equal to 1 let me write
it over here Y is equal to 1 X is equal
to negative 2 Z is equal to 3 that was
the result we got that's the result we
got so when we tested in this first one
you have negative 2 plus 1 minus 3 times
3 so minus 9 this should be equal to
negative 10 and it is negative 2 plus 1
is negative 1 minus 9 is negative 10 so
it works for the first one let's try it
for the second equation right over here
we should have so we have negative 2
minus y so minus 1 plus 2 times Z so Z
is 3 so 2 times 3 so plus 6 needs to be
equal to 3 so this is negative 3 plus 6
which is indeed equal to 3 so it
satisfies the second equation and then
we have the last one right over here we
have 2 times X so 2 times negative 2
which is negative 4 negative 4 plus y so
plus 1 minus Z so minus 3 minus three
needs to be equal to negative 6 negative
4 plus 1 is negative 4 plus 1 is
negative 3 and then you subtract 3 again
it equals negative 6 so it satisfies all
three equations so we can feel pretty
good about our answer